the most common archetypes these girls
you could tell they slept around when
they were younger them realized it went
South for them but instead of coming
back into the dating game with a sense
of humility they'll say things like oh I
had to cut everybody off I'm healing I
healed and this is the thing like
instead of coming back into the dating
game with some humility they think
they're better than everybody else
they'll try to shame women and be like
I'm I'll be shame women because I am for
bringing back Sam I'll try to act like
they're better than certain women when
they're really not you know you've done
the same so we can all tell because of
how dated you are it's very obvious it's
like a sign on your forehead and there
are also for women empowerment